he is the head coach of the Indianapolis
Colts joining us right off the bat to
use a baseball phrase Frank Reich how
are you coach rich I'm doing great
thanks for having me on
everybody good in your family or in your
world and happy and healthy hopefully
yeah appreciate you asking everybody's
good and looking forward to spending the
Memorial Day together as a family I bet
so so what's what's it like in your
world right now Frank are you are you in
your facility in the state of Indiana or
what what is everything going on with
the Colts right now yeah no we're still
following league protocol not you know
coaches players not allowed in the
facility so you know what we're being
productive rich I mean you know we've
adapted and you know learned what we
need to learn and it's not the same but
I'll tell you what I mean I think we're
getting as much out of it as we possibly
can how so what are you getting out of
it well for example you know on their on
our zoom meetings you know we're
figuring out ways to do you know we got
a new quarterback
so you know how it is it's a big deal
you mean to hear his voice in here you
need to hear him call plays in the
huddle you need to hear him at the line
of scrimmage call them cadence so we're
finding ways to kind of do virtual
walkthroughs you know make sure we're
trying to team bond you know like some
of those things you have to do on the
field and it's not the same but I'm it's
the next best thing and it's what we
have to do no I know that rookie
quarterbacks or young quarterbacks
usually are told by coaches go into the
mirror and start calling out players get
your cadence going sound more confident
get ready to roll
are you are you obviously it's got not a
confidence thing but are so Philip
Rivers is zooming in and you're having
them call out plays so your rest of the
offense can hear his cadence and pick it
up and maybe somebody like Jacob Eason
can be on that zoom and and pick
something up from it is that what you're
doing yeah no that's exactly right I
mean because there's everybody know
saying with every team that you know you
got to follow the rhythm of the cadence
of the starting quarterback so it's
important for Jacob and more important
for Jacoby you know because Phillip
saccades will be
be slightly different and what you know
some of the other guys used to I mean
after you know after 16 years of calling
cadence you know I'm not about to try to
change the way you know he's to calm his
cadence you know will adapt to you know
his style kate is that that's common you
know when you get a new one you have a
new starting quarterback so the guys are
picking it up well and and it's been fun
I mean what happened we're trying to
have fun with it you know we do stuff
like that we try to do some competitive
game you know we do a bunch of stuff
competitive quizzes what's really making
it work though rich is the guys you're
buying it you know if this doesn't work
there's the zoom stuff doesn't work if
the players don't engage and so our
players are engaging I feel like we're
learning a lot and taking some important
steps well there's a lots to talk about
about your quarterback room before we
get to your starter Jim Kelly would not
forgive me if I did not mention Chad
who's his who's up we just showed him on
the screen right there cuz he was
texting me like crazy during the combine
you know and knowing that you and Chris
Ballard were directly next to our booth
of the NFL Network saying don't forget
to mention Chad he said he's a different
person a different kid that he worked
with phil simms so on and so forth can
you add a little bit more to that Frank
yeah I mean Chad I cannot tell you how
happy we are the chat I mean he's really
made a lot of he's progressed a lot you
know as a quarterback he really works
hard at it you know chad is of course
you know I'm so close to Jim yep and I
know the Kelly clan is as well as
anybody and he is a true Kelly now and
you know if you're Kelly that that
that's a guy you want in the bunker with
you and you know you want him in the
bunker with it he knows how to fight
he's a good teammate and you know he
asked worked with Phil he's really
worked hard at his craft and he's
continuing to improve you know it's so
we got for a foreign camp it's going to
be really competitive
we like that though Chad like that all
our quarterbacks like that the more
competitive the better it's the way that
he wound up there is that it was it the
Buffalo connection with you and all
absolutely you know absolutely you know
I mean Chad was here's the second thing
Chad's working really hard on the field
but you know everybody know Chad had a
little he had one or two issues off the
field that I kind of put him on the
outside and you know Jim called me up
and said hey Frank he just means he just
needs a chance and and so we talked it
through I talked it through with Chris
and and you know we brought chat in and
Chris powered and I sat down with Chad
and said hey man you know this is it you
got it you got to make you got a beat
you got to do it right you got to do it
right on and off the field and I got to
tell you Chad Kelly off the field has
been as good as anybody I've been around
the guy as a mouth he's been a 10 out of
10 off the field as well as on the field
so I'm excited I'm excited for him you
know I had to bring it up because if Jim
sitting out there right now watching us
and I didn't bring him up I'd never hear
the end of it Frank so I had to bring
him up you know I always like talking
about Kelly's now I'm gonna as you can
appreciate yes my my friendship with Jim
goes really really deep
it sure does Frank right here on the
Rich Eisen show okay Philip signs a
one-year deal do you think this could if
it all works out
go longer than that Frank that's what
we're hoping I mean you know rich when I
looked at his film from 18 and 19 and I
was listening for three years for 13 14
and 15 and you know he was still playing
it throwing it and physically at a high
level and when I watched I watched every
pass he threw in 1819 you know when they
went 12 and 4 you know in you know two
years ago and then last year was what
was it not a good year for their team
but I didn't I didn't see any drop-off
physically so I mean I you know you're
38 he's gonna turn 39 so maybe that
maybe it happened maybe he hits the wall
at some point but I haven't seen it you
know so it's probably good to go year by
year but our intention is and I think
his intention is hey as long as he's
still playing at a high level and let's
do this thing let's let's see where we
can go we're excited I think he's
excited you know this was a unique
opportunity Brett
I mean you know we weren't you know we
were happy with a lot of what you Kobe
did last year we as a team struggled at
the end of the year Jacoby took a little
lebrun of that probably unfairly so but
so this wasn't this move was not so much
unhappy with you Kobe as it was and we
got an opportunity to get a future Hall
of Fame quarterback
who knows us and we know him so let's do
that and every year that he does play
for you that means st. Michael Catholic
High School needs to wait for the coach
that Frank Wright is that what that's
maybe what's the pick look I know his
dad was a coach maybe wants to pick up
some pointers from you while he's
playing for you maybe well it's funny we
were actually talking on the phone last
night and I swear he's just he's talking
like a coach but he's always talked like
that that's in his blood and I'm happy
for him that he has a clear picture of
where he wants to go Hey a few more
minutes left with Frank Wright got the
Colts here on the Rich Eisen show my
favorite draft choice and I'm not just
saying that cuz you're on your you're on
here right now
was Jonathan Taylor 41st overall I think
that kids is steel I think he is a star
you want to talk about off the field
I can't rave about him enough and I'm a
Michigan Wolverine and he kicked my
team's ass every single time he played
them and I couldn't he'd go more glad
that he's out of the big ten and now in
your world how much are you expecting
out of him and you this coming for me
work works best in a lot and it's like
you said we think he can come in and
make an immediate impact because he's
got the off the field
you know maturity you know to handle
what he needs to handle and to get ready
even in this condom coated environment
you know that he's mentally really sharp
his really high character I had so many
people calling me and texting me after
we picked him I mean literally it was a
lot of people a lot of football people
that hey this is my favorite guy he's
the off the field and on the field this
is one of the best guys in the draft I'm
kind of like what you're saying rich so
and I you know it's funny Chris powered
remembered him telling me at the
beginning of the year he obviously
everybody had their eye on Josh and
Taylor but you know Chris has some ties
to Wisconsin and you know he was I think
I've been hoping all year long that this
would work out so between him and
Michael Pittman
now I mean those first two guys are
really quality players and on the field
but we really think can be great
long-term leaders force speaking of
great guys on off the field when was the
last time you spoke to Andrew Luck Frank
I talk to him a fair amount you know we
keep in regular contact I got ripped
closes Andrew and the short time we were
together you know really happy for him
he's made a great transition he's really
happy I'm happy he's still in Indy you
know they build a home in Indy you
Nicole build a home in Indiana you know
I had their little girl and you know
she's really sweet
and so you know she keep in touch with
him every every couple weeks or so and
just to check in but he's doing great
is it true you helped him get married
Frank instead of fact yeah well and then
but when you come back to the states yes
part of the legal proceedings to be
legal was you needed a you know an
ordained minister to sign the document
and so I was honored that he would ask
and and then Chris Bower got the sign as
a witness so in my office before the
four of us stood there and signed the
documents to make it official here in
the States so you're ordained your your
your audience yeah well what did that
happen that happened between the time
that I got finished playing and got into
coaching you know just what had went to
seminary and school and and then which
really served as an interim pastor for
about a year and a half and so God
ordained in that process and one of the
reasons I did that rich was for wedding
purposes you know have three daughters
and I don't know why I don't know why
this vision had always been on my heart
but you know I just really because that
kind of stuff really means a lot to me
so I kind of had this picture in my mind
of being able to walk my three daughters
down the aisle on me and then turn
around and then perform the ceremony so
two down and one to go and that's
fantastic I loved every word you just
said but is there a way that I could
help you improve that story in any way
shape or form because I'd like to
improve things Eve
if it's not true Frank and if you'll
indulge me if anybody asks you when you
were ordained from now on can't you just
say during halftime against the Houston
Oilers couldn't you say that from now on
no vows for me I think we should go for
it go for it from now on
people hey when did you become ordained
a half-time against the Houston Oilers
man before I let you go
this new rule that's going to be voted
on instead of an onside kick you can go
forth and 15 from your own 25 you like
it to keep possession do you like that
idea for you you know what my knit one
you know this has been talked about for
I don't know about a year maybe when I
first heard it I was kind of a little
bit of a traditionalist no I'm not sure
I liked it but you know III think it'll
be interesting so I'm open-minded about
it
I feel like we can be a good team in
those kind of situations so if and when
we need it you know I would like to
think with our offense that you know
that it could be an advantage for us
relative relatively speaking oh I think
so too and we're already you know trying
to figure out who's gonna be the first
coach to do it when they're up to try
and get that vaunted two possession
advantage my first thought was Doug
Peterson that sounds like a total Doug
Peterson move but you know you're from
his staff as well would you do that
would you even think about hey you know
what I'll do the math fourth and 15
percentages this I've got to play in my
back pocket this is a way I can solved a
game away would you even think about
doing it up as opposed to something you
need to do to try and get back in a game
yeah I mean I'm not there yet I mean I
wouldn't I'm with you though I wouldn't
surprise me if Doug would do it I'm
pretty aggressive and yes I'm not play
calling but you know Doug might just do
it the fact after the first series you
know after the
touchdown he scores just to just to
prove the point so that's how that's how
his mind works but if I had to choose
the first quarterback who would be in
his coach's face to say we should do
this it would be yours though I would
choose Phillip over anybody else on that
that I would agree with you'll go with
that one hey Frank thank you for the
call appreciate the time unless so let's
stay in touch down the road always
appreciate our chats and our time
together
yes same race best to you have a great
week same to you that's Frank Reich
Indianapolis Colts head coach right here
on the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here